it's been more than three months
since aimon's father a peace advocate
and minister of education employee was
killed
on his way to work an explosive device
was placed in his car
iman wants answers the government is
responsible
to find the killers if they do not
find the killers then they are the
killers the un
says targeted assassinations by a known
assailants on activists
government employees journalists and
others
have increased by 50 percent this year
compared
to 2019. these attacks spread fear and
insecurity
often they are carried out by unknown
gunman
but another method is more lethal
magnetic bombs placed on cars have
become the signature weapon
for unclaimed targeted assassinations
they're inexpensive easy to use and can
almost certainly kill and injure not
only those targeted inside the car
but anyone who happens to be around
when the bomb explodes the head of
afghanistan's independent human rights
commission
akbar sees these attacks as an attempt
to weaken
and silence afghanistan civic society
we are also pushing for for civilian
protection
and more generally for ceasefire to
create an enabling environment for uh
for a peace process where there is real
public participation because if this
goes on
uh i'm just worried i'm just really
worried about
the fact that people will be very
hesitant to take an active role in the
process pressure has been mounting on
the government to provide
more security and fully investigate
these murders
the government says several people have
been arrested the ministry of interior
says
its investigations show the taliban the
hakane network and isil
are behind the killings our intelligence
section
they are trying to know every small
section
that they are connect in the big groups
of the tourists
that they made the plan
and they deliver the plan action plan to
the small groups and they
act they do the
magnetic bombs in kabul's city
after his father was killed iman feared
for his family's lives
and sent them out of the country he
stayed
to seek justice i'm my father's son
so he didn't he got threats he didn't
fear
and i am he going on his way so
i'm not asking for something should that
i should fear of it i'm just asking for
justice
if asking for justice should take my
life it's okay
asking for justice and peace felia
contra
al-jazeera kabul